[Music]
who saw the hunger games you see this
movie oh wow
yeah the hunger games made a whopping
153
million dollars this weekend can you
believe it
so to get in on the movie's success
before the hour is up only one of us in
this studio will walk out alive
spoiler alert andy lives
i'm good at hiding yeah
you are really good at hiding
uh hunger games is of course a movie
about attractive teenagers who were
forced to fight each other to the death
basically it's everything you were
hoping for the first time you watched
saved by the bell
someone give screech a crossbow that's
all it was
the first time i saw it this is crazy
the hunger games had the third
biggest opening in movie history
yeah uh
show business experts predict this will
be the biggest opening until snooki goes
into labor
[Applause]
and then i canoe back
what else is going on of course uh
dick cheney is in the news over the
weekend former vice president dick
cheney received a heart transplant
yeah
the new heart is working so well the
cheney's already gone to whoville and
returned all their christmas presents
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go cindy lou here's your watch
us
here we go cindy lou who on second
thought give it back
rick santorum uh caused a little bit of
a stir he swore at a reporter the other
day
remember what he he's i do yeah he said
bs bella without yeah without the
initials thanks andy
that was andy's midwestern way of saying
[ __ ] yeah he said yes uh well anyway
rick santorum said you aren't a real
republican until you've sworn at someone
from the new york times
yeah
moments later a panicked mitt romney
called the new york times reception desk
and said heck
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then he canoed back
can you enthusiasts know exactly what
i'm doing
i feel like it's true you got it and
then
yeah you drift right
he's parallel parking yeah
and there's a current so
what are you too babbling about
what's that
you stopped an amazing show to ask me
that
skulling i believe it's called skulling
thanks team
[Applause]
[Music]
i i think they're just over there doing
a crossword i think they are
they're playing words with friends
[Laughter]
hey over the weekend the pope made a
visit to mexico
yeah in fact one catholic in the crowd
one mexican catholic in the entire crowd
no he's in mexico yeah in fact it was
pretty exciting he took first place in
the spring break wet pope hat contest
the girls in that contest were really
mad
i didn't know he had to have a pope hat
yeah
president obama getting tough with north
korea
yeah over the weekend president obama
warned kim jong-un that bad behavior
will not be rewarded
yeah then kim jong-un asks so how do you
explain yet another season of jersey
shore just curious
i don't know how that works
[Music]
thank you
crazy story over the weekend a woman
broke into simon cowell's home
and he found her in his bathroom holding
a brick
that happened
yeah simon approached the woman
cautiously and told her paula put down
the break
[Applause]
hear this story a finalist from miss
universe canada was disqualified because
she was born male 1
yeah
judges uh became suspicious when she
listed her talent as hiding her
of a penis
[Applause]